we strongly believe that health is an
essential determinant and component of
well-being improved health status has a
positive impact on other aspects of
well-being such as educational
achievement and labor market
participation the potential savings for
society go well beyond the direct
effects on tp'ed GDP growth we also
discussed about Europe European
pharmaceutical policy that topic had a
really interesting discussion
safeguarding access to many medicines is
a challenging challenge requiring
measures both at the EU level and also
in the Member States
so duties and withdrawals of all
medicines pose a risk to patient safety
and increase the workload of health care
stop this morning during our discussions
are highlighted three priority areas to
the ministers which in my view are
particularly important the first one is
the area that has to do with cancer
arian the priority for myself very
important a huge burden on the economy
huge burden of citizens but most of all
it causes a great deal of suffering as
we all know I have informed the
minister's that I am glad to announce
that on February 4th which is World
Cancer day I will start an inclusive
discussion based on the Europe beating
cancer plan secondly I informed
ministers that I will work to create a
European health data space to maximize
the potential of digital technologies in
health
and this can be a true game changer for
our cancer plan because fighting cancer
without opening borders for services and
health data will not work it really is
imperative that this finally receives
the attention that it it deserves people
too often with mental health problems
are living in silence or are forgotten
and mental health needs to be understood
as a cornerstone as part of the economy
of well-being my mission is to try and
bring all stakeholders together on board
CERN to improve accessibility and
affordability of medicines in this
respect I really do need to emphasize my
thanks to Minister cure for her efforts
in the council to advanced than the
negotiations over the Commission's
health technology assessment proposal
this proposal is vital if we are going
to move forward and it does affect the
policy area of shortages of medicines